so we were talking about earlier the
exclusive interview we had with the four
Democratic congresswoman going
head-to-head with President Trump I was
always curious about that nicknamed the
squad where did that come from
I asked asked to do an interview because
we each represent first at the end of
the interview they said will you all
take a picture we took the photo and I'm
not sure who said it but just social
media culture said o'licious to a
hashtag squad goals are something like
gold
it was squad goals and then in morphed
into this thing but I said I've been
saying in the days leading up to this
moment that the reality is that anyone
to your point about it's not just about
dismantling but what we're intentional
about building and fostering anyone who
is committed to the work of building a
more equitable in just world is a part
of the squad so they're hoping that
squads gonna get bigger members they're
looking for new members but right now
it's the four of them and the four of
them are very very tight and very
connected and very uniting the job they
want to do
I'm glad you explained that name
themselves yeah it's nice to hear for a
change that's right